[Music]
pat joins us in sioux falls pat welcome
to the ramsay show
hello
yeah hey i just started a little
business in llc and i went to the bank
to get a
an account business account going and
they recommended a credit card and then
that they did well
yeah they did
and uh you know back in my mind i knew
what they would say but um
i'm calling to see if i was right about
what they would say no credit cards it
doesn't matter if it's business or
personal or nothing that
that that sounds about right to me uh
did you end up doing it
i did but oh boy um
but i can cancel it so i haven't even
got it in the mail yet like i said i was
going i was wavering and i called my
wife and she said yeah i get it you know
and then
and i still went back and forth and then
i said well i tried to call you guys
like yesterday too but hey don't put
this on us pat all right
i got voicemail you didn't sign up for
the credit card pat
i got voicemail so i decided to go into
debt
uh well pat tell me this what was your
reasoning going you know what i'm just
gonna go ahead and do that probably gave
you some good some good excuses well
i'll tell you i'll tell you what it was
it was um
my wife was thought the 1.5 would be
cash back would be
ah
cash back you talked to successful
business owners and they're like man the
1.5 is what did it so i'm going to be a
multiple you know a bunch of this it's
just a little small business and
i just you know it happened so fast
you're filling out all these forms from
this llc and everything else and
you know then this and that and so yeah
i can get rid of
whenever it comes to these decisions pat
i like to go who benefits from this
decision
and in this case the bank benefits from
this decision that's why they're pushing
the credit card is because they're not
going to make a whole bunch of money
from you taking out a business debit
card
they're hoping you rack up some some
debt on this thing and pay a whole bunch
of interest over the course of your life
running this business
so i'd like to win i appreciate you guys
taking my call absolutely thanks pat's
thanks for cutting it up as soon as as
soon as that card comes in cut it up and
maybe go to a different bank uh just to
just to stick it to them and get a
business debit card that is what bank
will do the same thing george well go to
a credit union i just don't want to do
business with a bank that sold me a
credit card that's all i'm saying that's
what they all do though right well yeah
i mean they're banks this is this is
what they do they're out to make money
that's what they're doing but uh that's
what we do here at ramsey right so we're
a big company millions upon millions of
dollars and we only use debit cards sure
believe it or not yep yep even the real
estate here
is paid for
we move at the speed of cash is what we
say around here um
and what it does though i mean from on a
business perspective is it makes you
make different business decisions when
you are using cash when you're using
debt there's a level of
oh we try to test it if it doesn't i
don't know you know you're not as
emotionally kind of freaked out but when
it's your cash you're like i'm gonna
make sure this thing that we're
investing in
is going to give me some roi you just
you have a deeper emotional investment
when it's your own money and then on the
flip side on the consumer side with the
points i mean this is when we hear all
the time george so people have credit
cards you know whether it's oh it's a
just-in-case thing
or i do it for the airline miles and the
points
and
what i've you know
one thing i want people to realize is
that you know when because people do pay
off their credit cards every month right
there are people out there they're
paying off and they're quote unquote
benefiting
and they are getting the cashback all
that but you understand you're getting
all of these points
because other majority of people the
average american is carrying 16 000
credit card balance so people because
they are mismanaging their money and the
banks are making tons of money off that
you now quote unquote get to reap the
benefits of a system that's screwing
people
and they're putting people in bad
positions so i'm like i don't even want
to play the game i don't even want the
points because because you're you're not
you're doing it dirty a little bit is
what it feels like because i'm like
because there's some
you know single mom out there is trying
to make her bills
and she's using the credit card to help
her in that because it's the only thing
she knows and i get a i get
a free 70 southwest fly i'm like no no i
will pay for my own southwest flight
thank you like i don't know it just it
drives me down there's a moral argument
to be made that we really don't talk a
bunch here ramsey solutions we stick to
the financial part but there is a part
where it's just it's a corrupt industry
and it's hurting people and you have to
decide do i want to be a part of an
industry that does this to people i
don't want to play the game and yeah 1.5
is not going to change your life it's a
few hundred bucks back and i tell i tell
people give yourself some cash back
that's what you can do when you live a
debt-free life and you have the margin
in your budget and if i want to go on
vacation i don't have to hope that i
have the points at the end of the year
we just budget for it and go on vacation
that's right that's simple yes so we've
got an episode all about this on
my podcast the fine print and it's
called the true cost of credit card
rewards so if this is you and you're out
there and you're going well what if i
pay it off every month and what if and
what if and what if and you're wrong
just go listen to the episode uh we
talked to an ex capital one employee
elena who really dished she spilled the
tea all right on on the credit card
industry 10 000 social experiments they
run you're just a you're just a mouse in
their maze wow when you get to the
cheese you think but i'm winning i got
cheese and then you zoom out and you go
no you're just a mouse in a lab
being socially experimented on wow so go
check out that episode uh you can go to
fineprintpodcast.com or just search for
the fine print wherever you listen to
podcasts